hello my name is Fred Ryan I'm speaking
to you from inside my garage and Clinton
New Jersey I'm a retired police officer
my question is is it possible to measure
the trajectory of a galaxy I'm
interested in learning whether or not we
can determine if galaxies are actually
moving in an arc and I believe that if
they are found to be moving in an arc
then we can suspect that they're
actually in an orbit thank you well hi
Fred it's actually pretty tough to
measure whether a galaxy is moving in an
arc we do know how to measure whether a
galaxy is coming towards us or away from
us we do that with the Doppler shift of
light but it's very tough to measure
whether a galaxy is going across the sky
in front of us so so far we're not able
to tell if it's moving in an arc by
observations but we can certainly
calculate the way that galaxies move or
should move because when we see a cloud
of galaxies with several of them in a
group or maybe hundreds or thousands of
them in a group we see them moving
towards us and away from is in a way
that tells us they must be orbiting
around each other so we calculate that
they must be moving in arcs even though
that we can't see the arcs themselves so
we're pretty sure that the answer to
your question is yes